very loving the show like loving it
great to see you back I hope you
remember me from Wine Library episode 7
5 9 where we drank out of bottles I
remember that my question I'll run a
video blog in my mug comm and get a bit
5,000 views a week but we've been kind
of there for the last hundred or so
episodes and should I click on sure be
bothered about that we're getting sales
from it we get lots of interaction from
it but should I keep on it if I am
should I look at dark posts should I
look at Twitter
what should I kind of do to kind of find
that next level
thank you for the show my pleasure my
friend I definitely definitely remember
remember you and that was a lot of fun
you know it's funny I was just about to
segue and closing out the show about I
also want more viewers and I want to
keep building like when you're in the
game you're in the game you want to
build and you've done the patience thing
which is normally my answer that's my
answer to me I'm only 18 episodes in and
you got to restart and rebuild an
audience and get people used to behavior
and it's not email or RSS like I had
with Wine Library Becca no six seven
eight and so it's different ways it's
Twitter but that's noisier and different
you know so I would say distribution the
reason you're stuck right now is you
need distribution distribution
distribution I highly recommend you say
to yourself what are the 100 websites
that are the biggest websites in the
world that speak to are in the genre of
my show and then literally email them
one by one and ask them if they want the
rights to distribute your content with
maybe you writing on top of it
I'd also reach out to the top 100
podcasts that you can get out there on
and promote the show give interviews
you need to hustle what you just did by
getting on this show worked you were
gonna pick up thirty nine forty to
seventy three new listeners for your
show by being on this show and you need
to just scale the living crap out of
that it's hustle hustle hustle hustle
hustle hustle hustle hustle but with a
thread in distribution you need more
awareness you need to show up on other
YouTube celebrities show you need to
show up you need to get into the
LinkedIn community and start putting out
that content you need to get the hell
out there that is the game my friend